you you told me once that the Bosnians
there they had they were called before
the bah-bah-bah what was it called
Bosnians the history of Bosnians Obasi
and muslims goes back to like seventh
century when when one group of
Christians Orthodox Christians from
Bulgaria to avoid the persecution
because they were they were believing
that their their belief was very close
to the Islamic belief like like those
early Christians you know that followed
the message of Jesus very closely so and
they believed in one God and also on on
some of their tombstones there was a
moon and and and and and you know just
like Muslims have a move our Crescent
and so they moved from Bulgaria West to
Bosnia into mountainous in Bosnia is at
record mountainous country so they were
they were they were being called
Bogomils bog means God and Mill deer so
they were called people dear to God and
the Catholics from Croatia were
constantly attacking them and trying to
cut a catalyst size them make them
Catholics and then they from from east
their Serbs were attacking I'm trying to
make them Orthodox Christians they
resisted that successfully by moving
into mountains and defending themselves
then when the Ottoman when the Turks
came the Ottoman Empire and especially
Sultan Al Fatiha
he brought Islam to Bosnia back in 15th
century and there were they and and and
they were very tolerant of these people
and that they found in Bosnia and they
allowed them to practice their way their
religion and and you know they were they
did not force them to become Muslims so
when when these
Bogomil sir how tolerant Turks were with
them they are voluntarily embraced Islam
there are cases that are you know on one
field in one day over 60,000 of these
people embraced Islam this is in history
in history document Wow
you know so most of the Muslims in
Bosnia come from Bogomils yeah and from
from these people that came from
Bulgaria and then some are from the from
the Turks that stayed in Bosnia okay
when the Turkish Ottoman retreated back
to Turkey after 1878 Berlin Congress
okay
and then some are local people you know
Catholics or Orthodox Christians that
embrace the Islam because they believe
in their message or they want to keep
their position you know in their society
yeah so but those are minority numbers
you know
and these extremist Serbs they hate
these Muslims and they column are
traders you know they believe that they
that Muslims before were Orthodox
Christians that embraced Islam when they
are you know Ottoman Empire came into
Balkans
[Music]
Allah there's only one word Muhammad is
His Messenger
ha ha
ha there's only one where Jesus was his
messenger